how's it going everybody my name is Matt
and you're watching my youtube channel
code Tecna toriel's and I'm doing
another vlog on this ancient Archer game
engine that I introduced last video so
basically in last video in case you
haven't watched it I basically said that
I was going to start kind of a new phase
with this game injury and I'd been
working on it quite a bit in the in a
few months previous and it was kind of
getting a little convoluted and I
basically wanted to do a reset so that I
could make it kind of how I intended
originally which is more of a something
to build on or to start a project from
if that makes any sense so previously it
was sort of a mishmash of games it was
like I was sort of building games within
the engine as a way of testing it so I
decided to separate that out and make
like an engine part that is something
you just used to add your stuff to and
I'm not entirely sure how to explain
that but basically the point is to be a
little more like something you can
script or something you can say hey add
this to the Delta time of the main loop
or add this to the update every yeah
this is something more like that and
that's sort of akin to the way unity
does it except they have a whole
interface I haven't gotten an interface
yet but that is something I would like
to do at some point where you can just
drag and drop things in and have like a
file manager and things like that but
right now it's all done with code and
scripting so I just wanted to talk a
little bit about that and maybe ask
again for hey if anyone's interested in
this and seeing how I'm doing it and for
me to explain more in detail and sort of
a how-to more of a how-to guide on
OpenGL and using the windowing system
with C++ and stuff like that then yeah
consider signing up for the patreon if I
get enough there which isn't a whole lot
basically I get 10 people signed up I'm
going to start doing some more detailed
blog
where I explained more precisely how I'm
doing things otherwise I'm just gonna
kind of do some winget videos like this
one
where I kind of explain where I'm at and
maybe show you a quick demo of what it
looks like but I'm not gonna go into
high details without any support as it's
just gonna take a lot of time to edit
that stuff together and and I really
need to go find a real job if I'm not
gonna make any sort of monetary gain
from this and I don't mean for it to
sound the way it probably does but
basically I have bills to pay I have a
family to take care of I can't just do a
bunch of stuff for free all the time I
can do some quick stuff here and there
but if I'm gonna spend real time on it I
need I still need to be able to support
my family and basically I got to go get
a real job
unless I can get support so I hope that
that doesn't turn anybody off to the
idea but let me know if you have any
feedback if it doesn't work for you for
some reason to sign up on the patreon
but you want to let me know there's
probably some things I could change I
kind of just threw it together real
quick and of course even if you don't
want to do that that's fine just
watching this video does help me to some
extent and given this video I like it
also helps a ton too so here we go I'm
just gonna kind of show you where it's
at right now eh I
I started kind of remaking the core
engine files and basically uh where it's
at right now is I've got the kind of
main display popping up and I want it to
be more configurable so that way
someone's running it on a different
resolution it should be able they should
be able to handle that and it should be
able to fit to their screen whatever
they want and also give some options for
whether you want it to be full screen or
you want it to be windowed and then
resize as you want so if I hit play here
and I'll warn you it's just a big red
screen right now I made the the
background red that way it's extremely
clear when you're seeing the unrendered
area so the unrendered area is red the
screen background that way the point of
that is when you're when you're making a
game you want to have a skybox and in
all your level and stuff and it just
makes it real obvious when you don't
have any when you
some part of this screen not being used
and of course you can go change that if
you want I'll probably give some option
for the end user to set that but right
now it's just behind the scenes so I got
the display and some controls in the
whole key input system set up that way
the developer can process the keys from
the keyboard and mouse so I'll hit play
here and it's just gonna pop up and
pretty much I have it set to take to be
windowed but max sized so GL fw3 which
is the windows window windowing system
I'm using and the controller or the API
that takes the control inputs now has
the option to see the usable size of
your window and cut out your little bar
at the bottom so that's kind of cool and
I set a quick hotkey to just make it
fullscreen so if I hit alt enter it goes
to fullscreen if it altered alt enter
again it'll come out of fullscreen and
go back to its windowed windowed mode
here so just getting that set up and
getting all the the key input ready took
a good bit of time as I just wrote it
from scratch and so I've got this little
test class now and basically all you do
is you instantiate the engine the engine
takes care of setting up the display and
controls and then you basically
configure the controls configure the
windows and then you run it there's
gonna be more to it
the next step here is really to start
adding the OpenGL context and start
adding in support for the developer to
say hey add this model and add this
player in and then start configuring the
logic that goes within the main loop and
I'm still kind of working on that but
basically the intention is to have the
developer set up the main what goes in
the main loop and what objects are in
there in the logic and I've also got to
do something for the interface so
there's a lot of work to do and I'm just
taking a step by step this is gonna take
a while
and I'm trying to work on it daily
there's some days I don't get to but
when I do I'm usually doing it privately
occasionally I do string
so you can check out my twitch stream
and and follow me there if you want to
see when I do live stream this show you
my desk my setup it's nothing really too
special just got the three monitors set
up this isn't the best look ever but
this is kind of my additional monitor
over there for checking stuff out my
main monitor for doing my core work a
little extra monitor over there a coffee
cup off to the side mic headset I don't
know what else is there to show this is
my area I have the cheapest table ever
I'd like to get some sort of standing
setup at some point but this is
basically a thirty dollar table that was
like alright I can't find a desk big
enough but this one is a big flat top
and it's easy to move around so that
worked for me alright that's gonna do it
for this video
peace out you guys keep on coding keep
on learning and see you next time